oh and welcome to dear Hank and John or
as I like to call it dear Matt and Hank
hey Matthew Gaydos is here I'm here this
is a comedy podcast about death where we
dispense dubious advice usually me and
my brother but sometimes me and a
special guest we also will bring you the
note news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon
Matthew Gaydos yes how are you but also
who are you the better question Who am I
why are you why why am i why yes I am
Matthew Gaydos I am a producer at your
video making company complexly
and you've been a video making person
for a long time yeah maybe you know you
from your internet things yeah I make
youtube videos my own channel as well
yet I get paid to make youtube videos
for sexplanations and animal wonders and
the financial diet yes well thank you
and we've been friends for a long time
yeah it's been about four years since I
moved down here yeah yeah I think we
knew each other before then little
Internet friends yeah yeah well thank
you very much for moving to Missoula for
initially of bad not a fun job yeah I
was just packing some t-shirts into some
bags and sending them out to the people
who are listening to this who ordered
pizza John shirts yeah thank you for
doing that no problem but now new job
yes new job man
so you're also I just I just heard that
you want to be a pod Conn have you got
your pod Conn ticket I have not actually
I'm planning on doing the whole
IndieGoGo thing soon though Wow so
explain me why you've waited so that I
can understand the psychology of people
who haven't immediately bought their
tickets for me it is a budgetary reason
that it's like for this month's budget
it's not listed right there so I'm gonna
wait until payday and be like hey right
now I can write it in to next month's
budget nice so are you taking this
advice from the financial day the
YouTube channel you helped reduce or
it's been every week on I'm editing a
financial diet I'm like I should be
doing that like I should have already
been doing this thing and I'm not and
later on they'll make another video
being like you know guys we already made
a video about this things that you
should be doing by now and I'm like I'm
not though they'd be so ashamed of me if
they knew yeah you can see getting
you're getting on top of your stuff I'm
trying that's good yeah
you considering your own budget first
before the budget of my convention that
is the way it should be but then I'm
getting the swag bag one oh yeah so
you're you're saving up for yeah the one
twenty five tier whatever yeah
cuz yeah that seems like price will go
up after the IndieGoGo ends its I gotta
get in there then so it just so you know
alright well did you bring a short poem
for me I did kind of bring a short poem
is it just the lyrics from a Green Day
song no but you're not that far off this
one I'll just I'll do every at first and
then tell you who it's from okay dig
through the graveyard rub the bones
against my face it gets real nice around
the graveyard once you've acquired the
taste and when the clouds do clear away
get a momentary chance to see that thing
I've been trying to beat to death the
soft creature that I used to be oh
that's uh off the new album Goths by the
mountain goats oh my god Court we should
only do John Darnielle
lyrics as dear Hank and John poems well
I was like looking up like Walt Whitman
thing and all this other stuff and I
what should I do
yeah and then I realize all I've been
listening to this week was the new
Mountain Goats record knows like well
clearly there's got to be something on
there pretty much boat like all poetry
what that man does I find that I sing a
lot of mountain goat songs to my son as
he is going to sleep because they're
good lullabies okay don't know what the
words mean that's also helpful that he's
young enough to not really understand
them I like singing love love love and
love love love has like a really sort of
sweet yeah refrain but then it's all
about yeah really bad stuff and you
don't want to seem like no children
right your child
uh-huh she starts understanding what the
words mean yeah yeah well I find that
most of the songs that I sing to my
child would not be good for him to be
listening to when do you feel like I can
although like every so I listen to
popular music so all like all the like
happy songs I know are fast and upbeat
and not good lullabies and all the
lullaby songs are about death and
breakups and car crashes and suicide and
it's just like well I guess that's what
I'm singing when do you think you have
to stop
that like what age I'm gonna start to
like comprehend the tone maybe before he
starts the tone is lovely yeah I was
like yeah there's like a Paul Simon song
it's like the the fritz and like the
lyric like don't cry baby don't cry is
in there and I feel like that's really
right it's a wonderful song boring the
bubble and but like the first verse is
about a suicide bombing and you're like
okay well that's what's happening I mean
he has to learn sometimes about the
horrible things that exist in this world
and so what better way than Paul Simon
yeah well yes and that's how I learned
that with my first exposure to probably
dub that very song I think a lot of us
learn awful things through the music we
listen to
yeah and and maybe how to deal with them
process things as well
but I'd like I fear the day when I have
to like sing baby Beluga to my child
because I like good music and oh yes
music is not good but he's no longer
entertained by the things you were
entertained by but it's love like the
majority of the songs I think to my son
know that was hard they might be giant
songs and they actually have kids music
yes which is extreme like it's super low
say you can like find those artists who
you really like also done kids albums
like Amy Dawson like that that's that's
well I'm gonna have to do yeah I think
and I think I'll be okay he will not
hear baby Beluga until he's like 42 but
this song I've got my father yeah
Raffy you know Katherine also really
loves Sesame Street and like Jim
Henson's stuff so like that's already up
in the house even though like you have
no idea what's going on there's lots of
no and I'm Bert and Ernie fan myself
yeah I'm more of a Grover man myself no
no really yeah what have you how I feel
about Elmo Elmo's alright yeah I feel
like Elmo is obviously very appealing to
kids because he is an infant yeah like
his character
whoever or who or who he actually is I
don't want to like break any walls here
well it's a part of my distaste for Elmo
comes from there's a documentary called
I am Big Bird yeah all about Caroll
Spinney who is the voice and performer a
big burden has been since like day one
and towards the end of that documentary
it gets kind of sad because they start
talking about that like the fact that
Big Bird's has been the person of Sesame
Street since like day one right kids
think about Sesame Street they think
about Big Bird he's their favorite and
then Elmo comes along yeah and starts to
be the new favorite because he appeals
to a slightly younger audience Big Bird
and so Big Bird feels like push to the
least that's not I mean there is nothing
more sad than sad Big Bird yeah like
like any like there are many sad things
in the world but like picturing Big Bird
sad yeah like his real tall head just
drooping a little God stop yeah
don't do it I'm gonna cry right here I
would avoid watching that documentary if
you don't want to see a lot of sad but a
lot of sad big birds Carol spinies had a
interesting kind of hard life at some
points and so it's a yeah it's a little
sad well I think I think it might be
worth watching anyway it did sound white
sounds oh wow okay I feel like we should
start with a sad question oh okay this
one's rollin yeah that's dear Hank and
Matt I'm a teacher this week a colleague
friend and mentor suddenly passed away
two days later a different former
colleague also passed away I want to be
there for my students but I also very
much am struggling on my own right now
how do i best support and care for my
students when I feel crippled by my own
sadness at this loss thanks for any
advice
Josh starting out on a highest note yeah
first Big Bird is sad now josh is he's
also said and also has to be there for
it this is like this is a hard thing
when like you have a responsibility to
people who exist in the world I think it
also but but like you yeah the context
we don't have is how old the students
are that's true well only matters a lot
my question is like are this to are the
students dealing with the sauce as well
I don't I think it's just a message on
his life so I don't think I don't know
necessarily that the students are
dealing with this but maybe they are
maybe it was a person at the school who
died I had that experience in college
where a professor of mine she was
married to another professor mm-hm and
he had passed away and none of us knew
about this until
she came into class one day very
distraught obviously yeah like told us
all while she was crying like what has
happened and be like maybe there's
another way to deliver that news well I
mean but it was personally for me I felt
like she was being very open and honest
and raw with us and mm-hmm
it seemed like this is what she needed
yeah I'm not saying that it's like the
wrong way to deliver it to you I'm
saying like maybe it would have been
easier for her to not have to do that
but maybe not yes I don't know but yeah
but like yeah I think that there is
definitely an age thing if it's like hey
kids hey third grade third graders I'm
dealing with a lot of death right now
yeah you don't know that is like I'm
struggling with that so I'd appreciate
if you imagined me as a human being and
that's not like the other thing is I
never until college ever considered my
teachers to be humans yeah I think most
adults don't seem like humans when
you're a kid yeah like they seem like
these all-knowing people who just spent
all of their life working towards one
like course of knowledge right right
they're like my Spanish teacher was just
a Spanish teacher and she never existed
outside of Spanish class yes but yes yes
she had complicated things going on in
her life and you imagine or did she
definitely she was doing online dating
and all this stuff and having troubles
and like who knows what she was doing
I don't cuz I didn't think she was a
person man I tell you what my Spanish
teacher was definitely not doing online
dating because that didn't exist there
was some form I bet there's a ole chat
rooms they're probably there probably
I'm first of all she was happily married
so hopefully she wasn't doing any of
them but you well I don't know how
happily married that's the things I did
have a bit of a crush on her mmm so you
were like I was aware of her personal
situation yes because you want it to be
but you didn't need to be that shouldn't
bring it up but you were like hey Susan
uh are you married are you seeing
anybody right yeah oh you're not we okay
got a weird question
yeah No
anyway yeah in general though having
like having to deal with your own issues
while there are other people relying on
you can be can be either just crippling
and anxiety inducing or it can help you
sort of like say I have to work through
this and I have to be the person that
this person needs me to be right now and
so that gives you a chance to sort of
either distract yourself or find ways to
get through it and and so like in some
ways like if there's a way to find
strength in that in the need of your
charges to need you to be something that
can be really good you can get you out
of bed when you otherwise don't want to
get out of bed yeah and I'm sure I'm
sure you've dealt with this being like
any managerial type in position having
like being a superior to other people at
jobs like I've been a manager to people
at jobs and there are days you come into
work and you don't feel like working you
don't feel like being happy or leading a
meeting or something like that and you
want to still have your co-workers Ren
colleagues doing the job they need to do
and feeling inspired and you want to
bring everyone down around you so it's
yeah there's a somewhat of a strength to
trying like and motivating those other
people and sometimes putting on the
brave face actually makes you brave
sometimes it's you're like I'm lying to
myself and I hate it and I can't handle
it and into a scible you like yeah you
have to you have to just deal you have
to find ways to do that you have to find
professional to talk to and like grief
is like the number one reason people go
talk to people who professionally help
people work through problems and so
that's absolutely a suggestion and an
option and a lot of jobs I mean I
wouldn't say it necessary a lot of jobs
but hopefully a lot of jobs out there if
you go and talk to a supervisor or a
colleague or something they may be able
to facilitate something where you could
take a day off take a half-day yeah yeah
and deal with this on your own if that's
what you need yeah absolutely and
hopefully the people that you work for
the administrators at your school will
be understanding of that all right this
next question dear Matt and Hank you may
be aware of the conspiracy theory
believed by 12 million Americans which
posits the presence of an inch
alien race of reptilian humanoids hiding
amongst controlling humankind according
to this theory there are countless
reptilian human hybrids going about
their daily lives who may not even be
aware of their true heritage among the
characteristics purportedly present in
these hybrids are one a tall stature
mm-hmm a love of space and science Oh a
desire to seek wisdom or knowledge okay
and a compassion for the fate of mankind
really it's very specific yeah
reptilians also often have jobs which
place them in the public eye
my question is for Hank are you aware
that you may be a reptilian-human hybrid
thanks from Bethany I thought the
question was gonna be are you are you
aware that Rhett of rhettandlink is
definitely a reptilian-human hybrid you
could both be reptilian in size it's
true but like Rhett could fit like
several reptiles inside of him he's like
six eight you just do reptiles in a man
suit is wearing my ogre suit I yeah well
first of all yeah I don't know and I
think that yeah that's interesting how
do I find out I could be we could be an
I mean I have cut myself and I have bled
human-looking blood I have had surgery
people have like I had a hernia repair I
had a colonoscopy and they were never
like you know yeah they never kept me up
and they were like where's your
diaphragm yeah well you don't have a
spleen there's eight hearts in here none
of that happened that's good
but you never know how accurate these
reptile people things are and I also but
I would say that it seems like it's not
a bad rap so like you're you love space
and science you seek wisdom and
knowledge you compassionate for the fate
of humankind and you have a job in the
public eye aside from the whole
controlling human kind thing this is a
pretty positive hey I would be like I
try to control humankind that's one of
my goals that's right I'm really in a
positive way I think what they are kind
I think yeah but anytime I've seen these
I hadn't iliyan conspiracy I haven't
heard that that part of the reptilian
conspiracy that they're kind of here to
help
yeah they're here to help I'm totally
down for it come inhabit our bodies
reptiles get us through this very
difficult period in this our species
survival does it say it's easier now to
pick out who's not a reptile right if
they're not compassionate mankind yeah
clearly not a reptile yeah I don't know
that that's actually part of it but if
it is like like maybe they were trying
to like cater this a little bit more
towards you yeah maybe but if that's the
thing like I'm super down for it and
also like I be okay finding out I'm a
reptile right I don't want to find out
I'm a Cylon and I'm here to destroy
humans yeah like a secret code that's
been inside of you the whole time that
yeah suddenly you can just flip a switch
and it's like oh no now you're a jerk
right yeah I don't want that now that'd
be bad if you as soon as you hear some
classic rock song I yeah I mean I think
I think if I'm not I'm as close as you
can get based on this description yeah
you're pretty much like you're
definitely tall love space and science
yeah shows about both of those things
which puts you in the public eye yeah I
mean it I hope that there are reptiles
doing this on earth is that okay I hope
it I hope that this exists I've this is
one of those like Wikipedia wormholes
I've definitely fallen into yeah like
those jobs yeah and like different ones
like Flat Earth and all the stuff where
you fall into it and you want to try and
understand the people who believe this
and why they believe this yeah and I
think this is one of those where it's
explaining away these people who are
held to a higher regard and are out
there in the public eye or in
politicians and celebrities and like
well clearly they must happen alien race
how helps yeah would a GigE Azalea have
gotten popular clearly an alien an
Australian rapper ha no alien rapper
with a with a Georgia accent yeah what
has happened nope alien definitely alien
I I sort of have a hope that someday
there will be a system that exists
that is external to humans that gives us
some ability to like not have to make
all of these very hard decisions that we
are suddenly all tasked with with and
maybe it already exists in the form of
these reptiles like I thought it helped
I love freedom I'm a huge fan of freedom
but sometimes there is too much choice
and like I like likes I'll uh yeah I
love freedom but I just want somebody to
tell me where my wife and I are going
for dinner tonight and for that to be a
compassionate nice choice yes and
towering it's like Taco Bell ha got you
Taco Bell I want to give me some of
those nacho chips things that are made
out of chicken mmm I haven't had one yet
today I love taco bell tacobell' r8 i
don't know why but yeah shows like threw
them under the bus so I don't know in
the end I have no idea because that's
part of the conspiracy theory is that
apparently people aren't sure yeah I
don't know I feel like that's most
conspiracy theories right is that people
aren't too sure but they really want to
believe are there any conspiracy
theories that you are kind of like I
mean besides that no I mean are there no
I feel like you and I are like a similar
skeptical brain and there's probably
something that I'm like mmm but I don't
I haven't locked on to what it them yeah
there's like oh no of course reptile
people and platters and other stuff but
maybe this one like I'd like to get one
I'd like to have a pocket conspiracy
theory that's harmless and that I'm into
I want to believe in Bigfoot well the
thing is there have been actual
conspiracies yes
like Watergate was a conspiracy you know
there's like the the human experiments
with LSD and you know giving American
citizens diseases because they were not
white and we wanted to do research on
them and like those conspiracies really
existed and then they were uncovered and
like so there probably are conspiracies
that have not been uncovered so you're
saying there is a Bigfoot no I bet I
I wouldn't I'm totally down for aliens
have visited earth okay I could be there
for that I'm not saying it's happened
I'm not yet it's likely but like I'm
like I'm also not saying it's impossible
but yeah there are a lot less UFO
sightings now that we all have cameras
in our pockets surprisingly well and
that's the thing I don't think that it's
I don't think any of the current like
crop of evidence that there were UFOs
yeah are makes sense because I think
that alien races if they are able to
travel travel through interstellar space
at manageable speeds have technology
advanced enough that we wouldn't like be
like hey they did scratch their ship on
a planet like something went wrong now
yeah yeah I use yeah there's I used to
be really obsessed with a lot of
conspiracies when I was like 11 or 12
and just like watch endless VHS
documentaries about these things and at
the end of the bay come to no
conclusions and like not decide which
side I'm on
which I feel like is maybe the good way
to do that probably yeah to know about
them but not necessarily just dive in
and believe all of them oh yeah I mean I
think like yeah it could be it can be
very seductive and also like destructive
because yeah because a lot of times the
conspiracies now are like conspiracies
are like this reptilian one for example
is tied up inside of you know a fear of
other people or certain groups of PS and
it's like Oh like like I knew the
Democrats were evil there's basically
yeah that's you don't want to go there
necessarily I have the question all
right it's from anonymous who asks dear
Hank and Matt so I've been dating this
guy for about three months and he has
snakes and he went on vacation and he
asked me if I could water them I liked
the idea for watering this makes yeah
like with the water hissing oh no just
like wet them down so I did very
carefully with the venomous ones how
many snakes are there and why are there
any venomous ones anyway but I
accidentally left one container open and
the snake escaped and I felt very bad
and guilty eventually he found it and it
was alright but I basically felt like it
killed someone's puppy of course I
already apologized but what do you do
when you do something terrible by
accident and need to be as advice would
be greatly appreciated anonymous
what you do Matt ah well first of all I
want to say accidentally letting a
venomous snake out of a cage is very
different from killing a puppy yes so
don't don't though it could result in
the death of a puppy it could that's
naked I got ahold of Rex and as long as
there's no puppies in the house yeah it
is different but I understand for sure
like like there are mistakes you can
make that are that are much bigger than
the mistake you made like for example if
we take this to a different level and
say your friend asked you to feed their
cat for a week and you forgot that's bad
like that's like but it's not an
impossible mistake to make no I will say
piece of advice to the world if you do
that and you ask your friend to feed
your pet text them the first or second
day and be like how's spotlight doing do
you thing for it cuz it's not bad and
then like and then every like it just
minimizes the chance that is a small
mistake that will have a tremendous
friendship ending result does not occur
especially and it's weird to call this a
small mistake because it is a huge
mistake
but it could have been I guess the
mistake itself doesn't feel big to me
because yes it got out but everything
well no I'm saying the cat like if you
don't feed a cat oh yeah the cat ones
bad yeah but like it's kind of still a
small mistake in that it's it's
something that just might happen and
it's not malicious and it's not like
it's not something that's like an
everyday activity that everyone is
expected to do it's just you spaced and
you killed a cat and that shouldn't be
possible
yeah I went to a weird place with this
that's all right but it reminds me of a
time that you asked me to feed your cat
yeah and a thing happened while I was
feeding this oh yeah you know about this
it's not a surprise I'm not scaring you
this on you here in the podcast but I
was going upstairs to get the dish
mm-hmm to get the food in and as I was
bringing it back downstairs I tripped a
little bit coming down the stairs and I
dropped the food dish yeah and broke it
yeah into a few piece I remember
for this yeah and then you went to
Petsmart and you bought the dish that
looked as much like the dish you broke
as possible which was way overboard
right but I'm in my head I was like what
if this was like a weird birthday gift
like a carry-on for for cap generations
like a weird family like heirloom for
your cat that was really important and I
was like I broke the one cat heirloom
they have and so I literally like went
to the store and I couldn't find the
exact same one but I found one with like
a similar pattern and I remember texting
Catherine and being like hey I'm sorry I
broke a cat dish but here's this thing I
bought it looks similar I'm sorry yeah I
really do we have another one yeah yes
but to Anonymous's question yes now that
we've gone on lots of bad directions
when you make them I think that the only
thing you can do is feel real bad and it
sounds like that's what you're doing so
sometimes people are like I don't want a
fee I don't want to have a bad feeling
because because like it's it's bad and I
shouldn't have to have bad feelings I
think that you should have yeah you
definitely need bad feelings from at a
time yeah and and I think that like
understanding what you did wrong well
the other thing I want to say anonymous
you are afraid of these snakes yeah you
were maybe not the best person to ask
well also how if you're afraid of a
snake do you make the mistake of not
keeping it under control and if there's
like a bunch of them and they're
venomous and you don't like them that is
a thing that first on the list should be
make sure they are securely yeah I had a
snake when I was a kid I just a garter
snake that we found Oh getting like it
became our pet snake and it's not like
we had a friend who when when they came
over we had to cover the snake up so
that she couldn't see it which I always
thought was very weird because you want
to be able to see the snake you want to
know that's where it is yeah do you want
a magic trick of pulling off that cover
and being like oh thanks I don't know is
it inside your pants maybe anyway I
think that you I think that you handled
it well yeah and I think just in that
case being honest with the person is the
first thing you have to do
yes ding this happened there's a missing
snake it's a house somewhere and sure
they may not ask you to watch their
snakes again yep right well in general
not even like the bigger question of
being like what do you do when you make
a make a small mistake that could have
had big consequences yeah and you feel
really bad about it and sometimes like
sometimes terrible bad things happen and
like it you have to like move on in a
different way with your life and
something and sometimes in this case it
doesn't seem to have like just because
it might have had a severe consequence
doesn't mean that it did right and you
can't undo it yeah so at the end of the
day like being honest with the person
telling them what you did now you're
sorry for what you did
but that like you'll try your hardest
not to do it again that's right
is yeah yeah I don't know what it's hard
cuz when you make those mistakes you
feel like the worst person yeah and like
they're never gonna forgive you and that
you'll never be again like it's it's
it's sometimes telling like if you've
had this done to you how did you respond
and like I've definitely had times when
people have made big mistakes in my life
yeah and you know sometimes I find it
easy to forgive them and sometimes I
don't and if and it's sort of like it
becomes up to them and you can continue
feeling bad about it but it seems like
the decision has been made you are
forgiven good work our next question
comes to us from Riley who says dear
Matt and Hank I work with a relatively
small number of people and today a
co-worker told me and some other
co-workers that she was expecting a baby
at the end of the day I was talking to a
different co-worker and I said something
like oh isn't so-and-so's big news
exciting only - and they had not heard
it yet yeah I had assumed that the woman
was telling everyone at the office the
news but then I wasn't sure and didn't
want to spoil it
so I awkwardly said something about how
they would probably find out soon now I
feel bad about having said anything what
is the proper office baby news etiquette
as fathers who were formally expecting
children oh this was for you and John as
far as design it's like I am NOT a kid I
do not have a kid but I'm not a guy I'm
not a I'm not a kid or do it have a kid
as fathers who were formally expecting
children your dubious advice is welcomed
well I will try my best to help well I
mean I was so so first of all you
there is some etiquette that falls on
the teller and I think that that like
that you know you can do it however you
want obviously but if you're gonna tell
the office might want to tell the whole
office like it's gonna be known and and
probably you're fine
probably it was intended for it to be
public news yeah it's not unless they
said hey don't tell anyone but I don't
tell I try I've let baby news slip
before and I feel terrible about it but
I try to just never tell anybody about
anybody else's pregnancy and I'm in a
place where I have now experienced about
8,000 friends getting pregnant as I'm
old and and a lot of my friends our
family types and I yeah and so like my
rule has become just don't bring it up
on West they're like nine months
pregnant it's like the same rule for
like asking whether or not a person is
like saying do you ask that question
when there's a baby coming up yeah like
when when like an it's a girl sign yes -
they're very large nine month belly yeah
that's when you can ask yeah there
should be like a decal that people can
put on that says yes I am pregnant just
to be clear just on any item of clothing
you just slap it on yeah it's a little
sticker the whole thing sticker is that
all works or maybe just uh it's probably
a tattoo was a bad idea because it's a
temporary situation you're not always
pregnant now you know it's not like once
you are you are forever how did you deal
with this when you were telling people
though I don't remember anything the
sleep deprivation of the last six months
has made it impossible to remember
anything longer than two days all right
so I don't know I I think that we did
like it and this is the thing like we
did a big announcement email at some
point like we told people like our best
friends early on and then when it was
the time when they say like the chances
of miscarriage have gone way down so
it's it's like you don't have maybe
you're not gonna have to explain if
something bad goes wrong
to as many people uh it's not as likely
that that will happen then so then we
did like a big
an email and of course no matter how
long we thought about who was on that
email we were leaving out people who we
knew like like later we were like oh of
course we should have had that person on
and then they feel like we're not it
important I should probably get my
computer of course we're not important
and I'm so sad yeah uh but like the
course I didn't say that but I felt very
bad for ya and especially if they find
out in a weird way and then I come back
to you and they're like yeah I had to
hear it from Tammy like yeah Tammy
mentioned just offhand yeah yeah and
that's and and so like it it's always
going to be somewhat a grapevine thing
and that's fine I was just hanging out
with a friend of mine who said that we
hadn't seen each other in alone they
said the last time we saw you we were
pretending we didn't know you were
pregnant because they had found out
through someone they shouldn't have
found out further they were like we were
hanging out with them and they were like
I guess we shouldn't congressional this
yet they haven't told us yeah so they
were like we knew and they weren't even
telling us I remember you told the
office kind of an all at once deal in a
big meeting you're like hey everyone
this yeah yeah and then like a day or
two later there was a like guest in from
out of town to work on some sideshow
stuff with all of us and we were all out
having drinks and you and Katherine were
not there mm-hm and this person asked
the group like oh do you think Hank and
Katherine will ever have kids and all of
us just stopped looked at each other one
and I like turns like I don't know the
person was like yeah I think it was very
clear that there was some information
they were not being given any fair I
think you like probably told this person
during that week but at that time I did
not think they knew and it was very
clear when they asked that question but
they did not know and none of us reacted
well in that situation the question is
did I have a baby or did I have a human
reptilian hybrid no no
well it's be like a quarter reptile I
don't know how it works well cuz
Katherine's not reptile she's not super
tall yeah
she's compassionate in the fairly in the
public eye though so who knows yeah
compassionate for mankind I don't know
how I don't know how it works
hmm maybe that original question asker
can write in to us and let us know if
they think Catherine's are a tile or a
my baby - oh yeah that's important ya
know - like so you can know how to raise
him mm-hmm
does he need like a heating lamp should
I water him yeah can we hire question
ask her from before to come water orange
for you
don't leave us cage open yeah he's
venomous maybe maybe I've been bit by
him several times but I hear a reptile
is it gonna affect it's true you should
bite you and we'll see what happens I'm
okay with not doing that day you're
probably a reptile too anyway
oh man probably hope so we might have
friends who are reptiles I also want to
be a reptile we don't have anyone on the
podcast who's not oh it's one of them
things well what is it called
I don't know it's at the top of my
resume this is reptile video maker
that's good it's it's important to
distinguish yourself from other
candidates when when submitting a resume
and yeah
yeah especially if you're applying to a
place that is led by reptilians Matt do
you want to answer a really hard
question sure we're gonna go to a place
all right we started off with a super
dark one so let's go super deep dear
Hank and John slash met when I read
slash imagined characters I imagine them
as white unless they are specified to be
otherwise is this personal bias or is it
racism hoping it's the former Maggie
well first I don't boy are the
definitions of these words not good
enough to cover all of the things yeah
we're never gonna say one or the other
and then walk away from this question so
while back on dear Hank done we had a
listener who wrote in who was from
somewhere in Africa and who said that in
a weird way they weren't black until
they moved to America because in their
old country they had the default
complexion
and then in the new country they
suddenly were not that and they had to
sort of give in like come to terms with
not being the default and in my culture
in America which is basically an
extension of Western European culture
white is the default race and that's
like this idea of a default thing is
kind of hard to get your brain around
but it once you look at it you see some
things so the racist part so the racist
is a strange and difficult word let's
talk about it so when I think of a white
person
the most important part like the most
like the identifying characteristic of
them the thing that stands out isn't
their whiteness it's not the color of
their skin because like that's what I'm
expecting it's some other identifiers
that they have probably applied to
themselves it's like they're like a
hipster or they're a hippie or they're a
bro or they're a nerd like you like look
at them and you see a thing that's like
they're like like an identity that they
have just no look like that white dude
who's a hipster right you oh yeah yeah
you are you versus CSUN later it's not
the first thing you see you see
something else and usually it's
something that they've kind of chosen
for themselves yeah and it's not always
the case so there are other things that
can other people like disability or
stuff like that size is also one where
like it can can suddenly be the first
thing you see about a person but that's
not like often for people of color
people who aren't white they're like
because that is a non-default thing it's
the first thing you see about them so
instead of seeing an identifier that
they constructed themselves you might or
I might see a black person or an Asian
person like as the first thing I see
like their blackness or their Asian as'
and then then immediately just sort of
like take the set of stereotypes for
that thing their skin color rather than
the set of stereotypes were there like
just sort of collection of their
aesthetic and clothes and haircut and
whatever that we are really good at
recognizing that pattern because that's
what we're good at we're we're good at
recognizing patterns so there's this
difference like it's not racist and I
hate people who aren't like me or who
have a different race than
kind of way it's racist in the humans or
pattern-recognition machines and skin
color is much more likely to be a
dominant variable in your pattern
recognition when it's not the default
color kind of way so it's not a
manufactured flaw that you have built
and created and it's been created by
your culture necessarily it's more of a
innate flaw like more of like a thing
that is wrong with you that's just sort
of that all people have like like it is
just a kind of laziness because I would
say some of it feels like it's built up
by yalter around you though because it
like it depending on where you live
where you grow up who you're surrounded
by your defaults are dependent yes and I
feel like I've definitely had this and
sometimes it slaps me in the face when I
realize that I'm doing it similarly to
like the question asked her or you're
reading something and then five chapters
in they'll describe a physical feature
mm-hm that you did not anticipate in a
might be skin color it might be height
it might be size and it might be like
gender often - yeah Oh like you hear the
word doctor and then like the picture in
your head is of a white man right and if
you say like a teacher or something that
like or a nurse yeah like people a lot
of people default ly like will picture
women and it's a thing I think you're
doing the right thing
question asker mm-hmm and acknowledging
it and realizing that it is an issue
right and a lot of people aren't aware
or capable of doing that because they
are fine with their default being white
or male and hearing the word doctor and
going like oh yeah white guy and a lot
of people are and just we're not fine
with it but just don't question it don't
like just yeah but even when they have
it pointed out to them some people are
like well yeah yeah that's what I think
that's what that's my default the Yale
the other thing is that like I so
there's this thing that some some
writers think like oh I'll just won't
point out what race anybody is and that
solves the problem of money writing or
like racist wait does not know because
because if if as long as you're writing
for a Europe like a Western European
issue audience like there's always going
to be the assumption that all the people
in your books
are the default race yeah and they eat
and but I also like
pointing out when someone is white
because it then says hey like it's not
like you have to like you have to tell
me one way or the other like yeah
especially with some clue if it's a
white author who is writing like sands
race expecting people to just sign a
race it's like well you're writing from
a white person's point of view as
characters like you can't just expect
people to apply yeah the idea that
there's like this like this that that
writ like there's no like because race
matters people who who are not white in
America experience their non-white like
I'm like so I am a white dude so I'm
talking about what I have heard from my
non-white friends like they experience
their non whiteness daily and a way that
I very rarely experience my race yeah
it's it's completely eye-opening yeah
you just talked to someone about this
and you realize how much they have to
think about this every single day every
hour every minute and again as a white
dude I don't think about this stuff ever
and it took me a long time like at the
moments when I do how I kind of the
defensive and attacked I get yeah and
I'm like wow it must be interesting to
like feel that way all the time yeah and
I mean it I think especially like I've
get defensive because I don't experience
it that often and so when people are
like white like frickin white guys I'm
like well not yellow I just did oh no I
did the thing because your default is
comfort and using the top of the totem
pole what kind of thing and it's just
yeah it's just yeah it's good to have
those things and point it out to you
yeah and like how you react to them is
very important
yeah and acknowledging that you could be
wrong oh yeah and you probably are wrong
about a lot of this stuff hey speaking
of being wrong about stuff I'll read you
this just this and this isn't a question
it's just a statement so a couple
episodes ago and this didn't come up in
the last episode just cuz we recorded
that one too fast to have gotten
comments we were back audience oh that
John could go on a writing vacation
which is why he's not here today
this is from Sheena no I saw a picture
of the Indianapolis Motor Speedway
Instagram it's an important inspiration
it's gonna be hard to write with all
that noise going around hey Green
brothers but mostly Hank coz John wasn't
there
good well John isn't here today either
in a recent episode someone asked a
question about women of the Islamic
faith who covered their heads and how
this is a symbol of oppression and that
made me feel a little icky while I am
NOT Islamic myself and therefore it not
exactly qualified to address this debate
neither were we to be clear this
semester and sociology of women we read
two articles that explained how covering
can be an expression of choice
liberation and control for Muslim women
in Western society as well as an
assertion of their right to belong in
the community I've attached them to this
email because I think they're worth the
read while there are places in the world
where women are forced to cover that
does not mean that the hijab is a symbol
of oppression for all Muslim women and I
think it's harmful of to Muslim women
and other rising to make that sort of
blanket assumption victory for the
forces of Awesome machinee and we will
put those articles on the patreon if you
want to check them out they are both
helpful and understanding that the
source of a tradition is not necessarily
the meaning of a tradition anymore yeah
and I think they really got the point
that at the end there were they say it's
harmful to make it sort of blanket
assumption yeah and that's pretty much
true about everything
yes but especially like in this case
like unless you have to talk to this
person and understand why they are doing
what they are doing making any
assumption about the reason they're
doing it yeah there was another another
person who wrote in made it who made a
really good point I think it may have
been on Twitter who was like it's
interesting to me so the question was
from someone who was not Muslim who
wrote in to be like is is it okay for me
to be okay with this system that seems
very patriarchal to me and that cause
patriarchal roots because I'm trying to
be understanding of someone's faith or
and a person on Twitter made the case
like why are you writing into a podcast
that is hosted by two non Muslim dudes
right why don't you ask someone who is
Muslim yes and try to find information
from somebody who's like making this
choice in a world where they don't they
aren't
forced to make the choice there you know
expressing themselves in the way that
they want to they're dressing themselves
in the way that they want to which is a
good point and and which is why I like I
probably wouldn't have taken that
question on if I didn't have if I wasn't
being co-hosted with a person who's from
a faith that has similar rules right yes
yeah I really feel like talking to I
mean not obviously going at someone and
being like why do you wear that right
that's not the way to go about it but if
you have a friend you feel comfortable
having that conversation with right or
or like there are like sources and the
Internet of Muslim people who have
talked about this right be maybe going
looking for those sources or you know
maybe going to like look for people who
are advocates like who are Muslim people
who are vocal advocates yeah and and
have conversations and answer questions
which i think is important because there
absolutely are like there absolutely we
do need to have complex discussions
about this stuff because just saying oh
well they're different from us and they
can do whatever they want because
they're different from us is not a good
policy and everyone knows that yeah
because if you take that to its logical
conclusion is bad but saying like
they're different from us and that like
and and I'm not sure that I like this
and but and then saying like so maybe
somebody can explain it to me is a
better way than saying
so let's write to my bike let's let's
talk about this with a bunch of people
who don't have any of the context right
like I think that happens a lot when
you'll bring stuff up with a group of
friends who you're asking about
something like this like hijabs or other
things and you'll ask your group of
friends who none of them are Muslim and
none of them
yeah like have insight into this
question but you all start to discuss it
and form opinions and have ideas and
then hopefully at some point you
realized maybe we're not the best people
to be figuring this out yeah maybe we
should reference some outside sources
mmm and take their word on it yep all
right Matthew I've been going for quite
a while now oh my gosh
oh my gosh this podcast is brought to
you by questionable assumptions
questionable assumptions among friends
who have no idea what they're talking
about driving forward confusion for
hundreds of thousands of years vodkas
has also brought to you by Taco Bell mmm
not that bad
if your reptile overlords tell you to
eat there just so you know this podcast
is also brought to you by escaped snakes
escape snakes possibly your reptile
overlords we're not sure but also make
sure you water them so that they'll grow
it keeps them happy and they will rule
in a happier way that's correct this
podcast has also brought to you by the
feeling of accidentally killing
someone's puppy oh my not that bad
unless you actually do it the feeling is
fine the feelings bad I will give you
that it's not great but it's a lot
better than actually doing it alright
oh we've got one more question before we
go to the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon's got me a long podcast
matthew i hope that you know you don't
have anything else to do today I had a
lot to do but it's ok that's not true at
all I was playing video games before I
came okay good
this one's from anonymous oh man well we
hit a lot we're gonna hit a lot like
there's gonna be mostly serious
questions today yeah oh my I'm gonna ask
one okay we're gonna do two questions
two more question more questions we'll
end on a lighter one than this gotcha
dear Hank and John I'm and Matt I'm 17
and I've been homeschooled my whole life
I'm graduating high school next year and
I feel terribly uneducated my mom
stopped teaching me and giving me things
to do years ago and is too busy with her
new full-time job to help me with
anything now so my education has almost
entirely fallen on me I've been trying
to educate myself but I'm really
struggling
I'm very behind in math history writing
and science like years behind I really
want to go to college but I don't know
even how to write a paper this causes a
lot of stress and anxiety in my everyday
life
I'm ashamed and embarrassed of how
little knowledge I have and often feel
like it's my fault for being so behind
is there any hope for me can I get the
education I deserve are there people
that I
and reach out to to get help from sick
of being unprepared and behind in life
anonymous a little bit mad yeah yeah
because bad mom mom yeah like if you
can't if you like got too busy to
continue this tremendous responsibility
you have taken on there is an
institution yeah available for free to
take it on for you the reason it's the
old school it's called the normal
default option
yeah the homeschooling I feel like it
sometimes people who feel like they can
do it better yeah if you can do it
better all but if you're clearly not
doing that maybe don't and what so so I
don't want to psychoanalyze your mom too
much but a thing happens and it's
happened to me happens to everybody
where you are in a situation where
things are getting worse every day
but recognizing that you are that you
have made the mistake you made
recognizing that you are have to like
liked a like face up to it is so
upsetting that and like also time
consuming and also shame inducing that
you don't want to recognize that it's
happened and in a longer version of this
anonymous goes on to say that they're
not blaming their mom and they like
their mom a lot and that their mom is
great but it this seems to me a
situation where your mom got in over her
head and yeah and and does not want to
face up to or this acknowledges it to
herself and thinks about this a lot and
it maybe it does weigh on her yeah
actually doesn't know what cuz it's a
pretty big G about I have to tell you
like anonymous this is a you would date
is not hopeless absolutely not there's
no undo you've hope for you but it's a
pretty big deal the situation you've
been put into and it is also an
opportunity and I'd hate to say this
this way but like if you think about it
as like what are you gonna write in your
college admissions essay are you gonna
say I love my mom very much but she
dropped the ball and so I had to do X Y
& Z like two really big adult things
where I
charge of my life so that I could get
back on top of this and I was 17 years
old and I wrote into this dumb podcast
where they give bad advice and I decided
to take charge of my life and be kind of
the adult that my mom wasn't being and I
called the school system I called school
administrators and I was like I need to
get into school I know I'm a little old
but maybe I can start junior year and so
that I'm not too behind and maybe I'm
gonna be a little older and maybe I'm
gonna have to work harder but I'm gonna
do it and or like I decided to take some
writing classes and to really dedicate
myself to those to take a GED class and
to really knock it out of the park and
make sure that I got like a hundred
percent on the GED exam and and so that
I could move forward with my life
despite the fact that this thing kind of
happened to me and then I had to push
through it and that's a good College
Admission story like they're looking for
people who have you know taken the reins
in life a little bit and not just sort
of like are falling and tumbling down
the path of the thing that happens to
you as a child but it that is like a
college-bound child yeah trying to get
in and be like yeah this thing happened
to me I'm not where I should be right
but help
yeah isn't necessarily showing that you
took the initiative whereas you have
that opportunity now to take a year take
some courses either getting into a
school or taking some like private
classes somewhere that you can get into
or a GED program or something like that
there are plenty of resources out there
yeah enter and like ideally like you'll
be able to have like a good talk with
your mom about this where you can say
like hey like like you in your email you
seem very adult
you seem very connected to how this is
making you feel and and and so like I
have a lot like I have it like nothing
but hope for you like I think that you I
think that you're gonna be able to get
on top of this you seem to be a good
writer already like this is well cos a
well composed email and it was it was
thoughtful in a way that makes me feel
like you you you're smart you're on top
of things so I think that you need to
have like a pretty serious talk with
your mom and be like I need to get like
I can't I can't just self motivate
myself I can't just
watch Khan Academy videos and be done
and while I think like I have never like
personally known someone who's gone
through this mm-hmm
I know that this person is not the only
one yeah there are communities out there
I'm sure online of people just like you
who have been through this exact same
experience and I'm sure it's been going
on since homeschooling has been a thing
where people feel unprepared right I
mean I did a little bit of research and
there's like there's a huge scale of how
this might go there are people who come
out of homeschooling illiterate and so
like I can tell that you're not there
right you're you are and and there are
people who go to college who are
tremendously unprepared who have gone
through public school and right that's
why placement test exists and they can
help you like even if you end up
deciding to go to a college instead of
like taking GED courses and so forth at
first a lot of colleges will work with
you and shape your curriculum around
what you are prepared for they're not
just gonna throw you into something if
anything college advisors will tell you
hey maybe you shouldn't do all of these
courses or this heart of a course in
your first year like they are there to
help you and and try and like get you
the best education possible yeah yeah so
I will say that you might not be as far
behind as you think you are there are a
lot of people who are pretty far behind
when they go off to college but I do
would also say like be ready to work
more than the rest of people and like
and that's gonna make a huge difference
and people will know like your
professors and your teachers will know
when you're working harder because you
have some stuff to make up for and don't
be afraid of that because like working
hard is the best skill you can develop
and I think talking to those other
people who have been through this if you
can reach out yeah man you can find some
it'll make me feel less embarrassed yeah
this because you won't feel like the
only person who's ever gone through this
mm-hmm because I'm definitely are not
definitely not all right our last
question comes from Casey who asks dear
John and Hank and Matt was talking with
a good friend of mine of six years when
we stumbled onto the idea of space
travel to mercury my argument was along
with several obvious facts that mercury
is too close to the Sun but my friend
proceeded to raise his voice calling me
an idiot because you would just go in
the middle of winter and at night the
Sun would be like 80 degrees do you have
any advice for what to name my dog when
I moved to Canada to avoid my former
friend from Casey I took a turn it's not
exactly right speck at that question but
I did I did have to read it twice before
I understood the the implication like
you had to make sure that someone didn't
accidentally delete half of your
questions like what this is the same
person a second question okay yep so
first there's there's two things
happening you think your friend is an
idiot because they don't understand
mercury your friend thinks you are an
idiot because they are wrong about how
mercury works I'm gonna be the third
person and tell you that you're both
idiots because you're both wrong mercury
is hot on the on the side that's facing
the Sun mm-hmm but during the time when
it's not facing so it's bit it rotates
yeah so there is a like that like the
whole planet does occasionally
experience the tremendous like iron
melting heat well not great for travel
not great but on the side that's dark it
is winter but like very cold right like
deathly cold 90 degrees not even out but
I will say that if one side is hot and
one side is cold somewhere on the planet
it's 80 degrees use it to stay in that
spot you just have to follow it around
if it moves you know yeah real fast
mercury car the and in science fiction
there is a there's an idea of like a
train that goes all the way around
mercury and the Train has a city on it
and the city moves along that that area
of mercury that is neither in the in the
Sun or in the dark it is well it's in
the dark but it's like close enough that
it's still cool and like if it stops
moving everything catches on fire so
let's not go to mercury probably right
right it's complicated but what I want
to say is that everybody in this
situation me Casey and Casey's friend
all assumed that the person was an idiot
and dumb and wrong this is true and so
friendship should end
or should both Casey and Casey's friend
and me think maybe it's more complicated
than I think it is and I do agree Casey
that this is frustrating that your
friend got mad at you for being an idiot
but you should not be frustrated your
friend for not knowing something because
that is the joy of living on earth is
that we are all always learning and
knowing more things and clearly this
dog's name is going to be mercury that's
a good dog name like that's your only
choice at this point is there so Pluto
is a dog yeah well is there another dog
named after a planet Uranus goofy goofy
I don't think we've discovered that
planet yet I bet there's a planet named
after goofy not a planet but some like
some astronomical object know we always
named them just weird number
combinations now Ceres is a dog is it I
think they're a dog named series I think
so I'm googling it I'm going through all
the planet names now like I mean people
have definitely named their dogs like
Venus or Neptune Neptune is not a bad
dog name either but this case I think to
really stick it to your friend since
you're gonna move away because of him
right mercury yeah
Ceres is not a dog series was is the
goddess of Agriculture and grain crops
fertility and motherly relationships
originally the central deity in Rome's
so called plebeian or Aventine triad so
if you have got a real motherly dog yeah
name it series it's good I don't know I
thought Ceres was a dog Cerberus maybe
server server is that's why were you
going yeah so that's just what I wanted
to say Matthew Gaydos do you have some
news from AFC Wimbledon I do have some
news from AFC Wimbledon is a good news
to not go with the scores or the trades
earning at that okay I wanted to bring a
little bit of a twist to the news from
AFC Wimbledon here so it's been a year
since that magical night in Lincolnshire
Network that I'm probably pronouncing
ready represent correctly
but this was a dramatic wind against
Accrington to mark the occasion AFC
Wimbledon on their delightfully named
auction website AFC Bey is it really no
it's just it's a link to ebay but they
call it AFC Bey
go visit AFC Bey they're auctioning off
some items okay but that benefit the
club because this is you know AFC
Wimbledon is like she owned by the fans
get something for John well you have two
great options that I'm going to tell you
about right now
one is a pair of shorts from that game
that were worn by the monster Randy
Messiah
Lisle Taylor these are the shorts I
don't know if they've been washed not
sure I hope not but they are currently
going for 52 pounds on AFC Bay okay how
long is the how long it goes through May
28th I believe so if anyone out there is
interested in getting wild Taylor's
shorts you have very little time because
this is gonna come out on like at 27th
there you go
if I don't know well I don't know if you
are ace of a slightly larger stature and
would like a different pair of shorts
they also have a pair of auto bio Aachen
phenoix shorts Wow so you can go pick
those up which are actually currently
going for a higher 56 pounds okay with
nine bids so nine people have already
bid on his shorts there are also things
like signed photographs of first team
players coaching staff you can get
programs signed posters DVD box sets
there's a lots of options but they're
having a cool auction going on right now
to benefit AFC Wimbledon and I will say
this is great this is what good I assume
will do news Matthew gun there is a
twitter that is just the AFC wimbledon
ebay twitter is it at AFC bay
it is AFC wimbledon i assume let me look
and see what AFC Bay is probably
something with absolutely no tweets but
that is how it works
AFC Bay tweeted
I don't ever know they can get though I
don't know why they don't use AFC Bay
you guys I do love that at the bottom of
this article talking about I'll be on
the auction items it says there are
plenty of other non football items that
you can also bid for including sign
footballs maybe there's maybe they're
actually like American footballs and so
like it's not it's a different kind of
football oh my goodness do you have some
good news for us from Mars I have a
little bit of Mars news yes so Mars as
we now know was once a wet place right
some some scientists have done some
science that's what they do they are
wanted to do they have to you like every
so often to keep up that title and have
have determined that using basic
physical principles to understand the
relationship between the atmosphere
raindrop size and rainfall intensity we
have shown that Mars would have seen
some pretty big raindrops how big they
would have been able to make more
drastic changes to the surface of Mars
than earlier fog like droplets okay how
big an atmospheric pressure equivalent
to that of Earth's for example Martian
raindrop would likely have maxed out
about seven point three millimeters so
about one millimeter larger than current
earth drops which doesn't sound like a
lot but you wouldn't notice it yeah so
this is the thing that like there is
there like you know this but it kind of
is a little counterintuitive that
raindrops have size is that wrong it's
nothing I've ever thought about yeah but
they do like I had a big ol fatty rain
yeah and in Florida you like walk
outside you get hit like a train drops
you're soaking wet
yeah here you can walk all the way to
work it's raining the whole time and
you're like I was at a barbecue
yesterday and we it rained for like an
hour and none of us went inside because
it was fine
yeah this is very dry here but the rain
does fall out of the sky because as
heavier than air and the largest
recorded raindrop on earth was about an
inch in diameter that's it's a big
raindrop like that's like a that's like
pow I just like I'm like a hail where
did they measure it like how yeah right
yeah look at that eh
I think that could have been the one and
they just happened to be waiting there
with a little measurement tool be like
oh this is life it just like holding up
a little ruler you know I think what has
guys guy diving next to the rain drops
that's not even how you want to do it
though because you don't want to measure
up there because they're gonna be
biggest when they hit the crowds true
but yeah we think what happens is they
they're looking at how how many
raindrops are falling and then they
measured the amount of water that's
collected and then they infer from that
how big the drop would if the Ray that
makes more sense rather than like using
a high-speed camera or something that's
like got a ruler behind it the slow mo
guys I know these raindrops are yeah but
uh a quote there will always be some
unknowns of course such as how high a
storm cloud could have risen into the
Martian atmosphere but we made efforts
to apply the range of published
variables for rainfall on earth it's
unlikely that rainfall on early Mars
would have been dramatically different
from what's described in our paper our
findings provide more definitive
constraints about the early history of
water and the climate on Mars so they're
doing doing scientific analysis making
models of how the rain would have
happened because it's interesting like
on a planet with less gravity you have
more up like the like if you have the
same amount of atmosphere and more and
less gravity then like all that stuff
sticks around up there for longer
because what happens with raindrops is
they get blown around and that's like as
long as they're getting blown around in
the cloud they're picking up more water
and then when they fall out that's like
that's as big as they're gonna get when
they get heavy enough to fall that's
when they fall right but if they if
there's less gravity
then they aren't it takes a little
longer for them to get heavy enough to
fall hmm which effects not just how big
the raindrop is but the hop but like the
geology of Mars
I mean you first said they were they're
slightly larger or they were larger than
the Earth's I was picturing like a fist
sized raindrop just like pound in earth
it's ready to be like guys yeah I'm glad
we were not on Mars then oh goodness
gracious what do we learn today Matthew
well hmm I want to know Hank yeah have
you ever seen the rain ah you know I
made that joke yeah on an episode of
holy frickin science I know I was there
that's why we were the only two who knew
that song I learned that pink and maybe
me who knows might be a reptile hmm I'm
hybrid that Matthew Gaydos felt really
bad about breaking my cat I felt so bad
I learned that while mercury maybe isn't
the best place to visit for a vacation
maybe is a great name for a dog in
Canada I think that's like also I like
it's not so easy to move to Canada as
you may think
yeah just running away from your friend
you can't just bolt across the border
with your dog in hand I'm seeking asylum
we had an argument about mercury and I
learned that got to be careful with
those baby announcements yeah gotta tell
everybody at once or you're gonna cause
an awkward situation or don't tell
anybody ever and just let it happen
yeah people be like quietly eyeing ya
your belly are you waiting like what are
they I don't know they never told me
yeah now that's a good and then and then
and then not even tell them after the
kids born and people be like yes yeah
yeah I'm not telling now like you should
have like not to anybody about Oren and
then like in 12 years
oh yeah that's my son he's like what's
up it's very difficult I would have been
really hard to justify the paternity
leave thank you for listening to this
episode of dear Hank and John thank you
for joining the Matthew house thank you
for having me it was great good let's go
to Taco Bell yeah get some of those
naked chicken chips or whatever they are
they're just it's not like there's
they're fried so they're not even naked
and they're not even covered in bread
there's only one way to find out we need
to do the sign it like the scientists do
and eat some of these non chips this
episode of dear and good John is
produced by rosianna halse rojas and
shared and Gibson our editor is Nicholas
Jenkins Victoria bon giorno is our head
of community and communications hey
thanks Victoria and our music is by the
great gunnarolla hmm as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]